camouflaged by the soot stained walls
these girls wanted to see her students
mini a similar age had died in the night
this was an Islamic school the children
were learning the Quran boys between 10
and 20 years old had been sleeping in
the school dormitory when the fire broke
out a police spokesman speculated an
electrical fault could be to blame
a fire that is burning on my wife a lot
of smoke
I mean a crowd swelled as the bodies of
the children were removed many neighbors
said they tried to help but there was
only one entry point to the building
there were bars on the windows the fire
made it too hot to enter they said by
the time firefighters arrived they had
got the blaze under control but it was
too late
[Applause]
the children were counted publicly
before they were swiftly buried in a
collective ceremony some offense to the
owner screaming for death in a heavy
fire was pitiful Sonia
normal margin on the outskirts of the
capital Monrovia Painesville is a suburb
President George where wouldn't usually
have cause to visit residents lined the
streets as he arrived in an attempt to
calm crowds and offer support
to die in the fire it's not a physical
thing
I don't even
we want to
now with that
[Music]
Islam is a minority religion in Liberia
but here in Paynesville support is
strong grandma I can only pray from when
I have my sea of the people who pass
away either today or the past thing now
all we can do nothing s an outpouring of
grief for innocent lives lost
Charlotte Bellis al-jazeera